has been nominated by the Scottish
Parliament from among the members of the
parliament to the first minister of the
Scottish government
now therefore we in accordance with the
vision of section 45 subsection 1 is
important that 1980 1998 hereby appoint
said answer
to the office of the cultural minister
of the Scottish government during our
pleasure
and we are doing this world to be
extended in the most useful and best
form and to pass and pursue appointed by
the Treaty of the Union to be kept and
made use of Scotland in place of the
Great Seal of Scotland
and for doing payroll please presents
shall be sufficient formed to The Keeper
of the registers of Scotland for writing
the same in the register of the great
scene and to The Keeper of the state
seal proposing the same to be attended
there too given it out quote said James
this 20th day of March
2023 and the first Universe like his
Majesty's command
foreign
there are three of them
first the official oath
you swear that you will well and truly
serve his majesty King Charles in the
office of first minister of the Scottish
government
and now in relation to the keeper of the
seal
you swear that you will well and truly
serve as Majesty King Charles in the
office of Keeper of the Scottish seal
and the third the oath of Allegiance
you swear that you will be faithful and
bear true allegiance to his majesty
King's Charles his heirs and successors
according to law
will you now sign the parchments
foreign
thank you
Minister on behalf of the court I take
this opportunity to congratulate you on
your election by the parliament as first
minister of the Scottish government
the position of first minister is one of
the great offices of State
it is a great honor to hold that office
but it carries with it many are just
responsibilities
like you said yesterday that you would
stand up unequivocally for the Scottish
Parliament and against any attempts to
undermine devolution
the courts too will continue to do their
best to uphold the institutions of both
government and Parliament
in turn it is the duty of the first
minister to uphold the independence of
the Judiciary and the legal system and
professions generally
although judicial decisions must of
course be subject to public scrutiny a
successful democratic system can only
survive if it is governed by the rule of
law it can only exist if the government
affords adequate protection to the
Judiciary from unwarranted attack so
that they can make their decisions as
the judicial oath requires without fear
or favor affection or ill will
you also mentioned yesterday that
Scotland would continue to be a positive
Progressive voice on the world stage
that too involves ensuring the
prominence of the rule of law as the
principal protection for the individual
against oppression of all kinds
in carrying out your pledge to work
ambitiously for the Scotland of the
future we will work together as we have
done in the past to improve upon our
existing systems of civil administrative
and criminal justice
there are many projects currently under
consideration
despite the burdens of office I hope
that your your new role will give you
great pleasure and fulfillment
the court will now adjourn